hey guys it's max in this video we are
comparing the brand new
lg gram 14 inch against the macbook air
now a couple days ago we compared it
against the pro and we realized that
this is actually the more fair
comparison so today we're not only going
to take a look at some benchmarks but
we're going to focus on real world
performance
with a variety of photo editing tests
some video editing tests
web browsing ssds and more i'm also very
curious about
thermals because the lg did get quite
hot compared to the macbook pro which
had a fan
now in this case the macbook air doesn't
so we are gonna pull out our thermal
camera
and we're gonna get a nice look at how
hot these guys get
so let's go ahead and jump in and we're
gonna start out with the
exteriors one thing that has really
fascinated me about
this laptop is how dang light it
is it's hard to kind of tell you guys uh
over
video and numbers don't always kind of
give you a good representation
but there's about a forty percent weight
difference between these
but because of that super lightweight
design it is quite flimsy so we press
down on the lid
we get a lot of flex and then if we go
ahead and open it up
right here you get a lot of flex even
pushing on the track pad
everything kind of goes down so don't
expect a super nice
build quality and it does feel quite
plasticky even though this
is some magnesium alloy material that
the frame is made of so you really have
to ask yourself
do you prefer something that is lighter
weight but a little bit more flimsy or
something that feels more premium
it's heavier but it's a lot more solid
go ahead and let me know down below
we also have a pretty decent difference
in terms of thickness
so basically the macbook pro is the same
thickness of the lg gram if you
completely take off this fairly thick
lid both on the back where we have our
hinge and if we spin it around
at the front we're both wedged down but
the macbook air is a lot thinner
now the lg does have some pretty massive
advantages and
one of those are the ports as you guys
could see
on the left hand side we have two
thunderbolt 4 ports
we have a headphone jack and a full size
hdmi
compared to just two thunderbolt ports
and then spinning this
around the air just has a headphone jack
compared to two
super speed full-size usb ports and a
micro sd card reader
and with all of those ports the lg gram
can actually support
up to four displays compared to two
displays with the macbook air
one of which is the built-in one so that
makes the lg gram sound like a big
powerhouse
but we'll test that in just a bit now
let's go ahead and open these up and
both have
really nice balance hinges for
one-handed open
and let's take a look at the insides of
course i love the gold macbook air the
color really stands out but i also dig
the modern clean white look
of the lg i've been using the lg grams
keyboard and i have to say that it feels
fantastic it has a little bit more
pressure required
to press down feels very tactile and
then the keys are a little bit larger
than the macbook airs
of course the apple's magic keyboard
also feels awesome so nobody's gonna
have any complaints with either
one of these now if we go ahead and move
down and compare the track pads
that is where the macbook air is on a
whole nother level
it is a magnetic trackpad so you have an
even click feel everywhere
that you can actually adjust to your
liking whereas the lg gram it has a
standard
diving board design now with that said
it's not too tough to press at the top
very easy at the bottom but once again
when you start clicking
you see all of that flex there so i've
actually been using it
just by double tapping without actually
clicking and it is very precise
but the macbook airs is still way ahead
now before we compare the displays
let's go ahead and take a listen to the
speakers if you have a pair of
headphones
put them on and let's see how the lg can
compare
without having these front facing
[Music]
grilles
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below
i'll give you guys my opinion and this
was an absolute
slaughter i it's like that now we
compared the lg to the macbook pro last
time and the lg was actually
slightly louder the track was different
but the macbook air
it is actually louder than the macbook
pro and in this test
the lg peaked at 77 decibels
whereas the macbook pro actually hit 80.
so yes it is louder
but with that the highs are a little bit
more clear
the mids are more rich and it has deeper
bass as well
so there really is no comparison and now
let's compare the webcam
and microphone quality this is the 720p
webcam
from the lg gram and this is the webcam
and microphone quality
with the new m1 macbook air go ahead and
let me know which one looked better
and which one sounded better down in the
comment section below
and now let's get into the displays
where we do have some
differences now first off the lg is a 14
inch display which
is nicer it's also a 16 by 10 display so
lg did switch over from 16 by nine which
is great for this size
and we have these nice slim bezels so it
looks a little bit more clean and modern
now the actual displays themselves have
a big difference in resolution
we have basically 2.3 million pixels
over here
1920 by 1200 compared to 4.1 million
pixels
and yes you can tell the difference as
far as sharpness
looking at text and icons we have almost
twice as many pixels
i went ahead and adjusted that top
camera so we can compare the displays i
max them out
and they look quite similar i would say
the macbook air is a little bit more
bright
but uh the lg is actually pretty good
for a windows laptop
we do have a bigger difference when we
compare contrast
the macbook air has much deeper blacks
the colors look a little bit more rich
as well it has a little bit better color
accuracy
and there is a pretty significant
difference in reflectivity if we look at
the
lg the screen looks a little bit grey
and looking at it i look pretty much
like a mirror where as we move over to
macbook air i'm much more
muted and i can focus on the actual
image
better so if you're looking for a screen
that is not very
reflective if you're going to use it
outside or in a bright room
and especially if you want to do things
like photo editing or video editing you
want to work with colors
the macbook air is the better way to go
and now let's get into performance
starting
out with comparing these 256 gigabyte
ssds
i'm gonna go ahead and hit start here
and one thing i want to mention is that
the lg
does actually have a second m.2 slot
that is available
for you to install an ssd whenever you
want to without having to replace the
original one so that is
really great not only do you have the
main replaceable one but another slot
that's very rare to see
where of course the macbook air
everything is soldered in so you have to
make the right choice
right away now let's go ahead and
compare the speeds it looks like a write
speeds
the macbook air is about 100 megabyte
per second faster
but in read speeds the lg does take the
win
by about 800 or so megabyte per second
so definitely
a little bit quicker there and next i
want to test out the web browsing
performance i have google chrome opened
up on both so i'm not testing out the
native safari
or the edge because that's what most
people use and we're going to keep it
fair over here and we have speedometer
web browsing
benchmark open so let's go ahead and
click start the macbook
is flying just finished up there we have
a score of 212.
that is an absolute insane score and you
do feel it when you're web browsing
compared to even the mac pro
everything is super snappy and bam right
there the lg
is finished we have a score of 142
meaning that the macbook air is about 50
faster at web browsing loading various
plugins
anything else that has to happen in the
background it is definitely snappy
and now let's get into cpu and graphics
performance now i do want to mention
that
the lg gram is not plugged in just like
the macbook air isn't and that is
because it actually doesn't really lose
performance when you unplug it
compared to a lot of other windows
laptops which is fantastic
as long as that performance is good
enough so i'm gonna start at the cpu
test
and the lg gram does have intel's
latest tiger lake processor this is an
i5 with the best g7 graphics
and it's listed to go all the way up to
4.2 gigahertz
compared to 3.2 on the macbook air but
we're gonna go ahead and let this test
run
and we'll see our score all right guys
we have our score
and the slaughter continues we have a
score of 49.71
on the lg gram and 76.33
on the m1 macbook air that is a
difference of
almost 60 percent a massive difference
as far as single core the lg game does
pretty good
uh but we still have about 25 percent
better performance
with the macbook air now i also want to
point out that this score right here
49.71 is actually
the highest that i've gotten running
this four or five times on the lg gram
with it even being plugged in or
unplugged so that is a fantastic score
the best that i've seen and now let's
test out the graphics this is going to
be interesting because
this macbook air is the base model and
only has a seven
core gpu not the full a core gpu
now we're running opencl here or this
one of course can use metal so we're
gonna run that
let's take a look the scores are in and
the lg got 14
651 which is fairly respectable and this
is the g7 graphics
but the macbook air scored 19 051
metal score so of course metal is more
efficient apple really
optimized it that is great but i also
ran
the opencl test which is a lot less
efficient
and the score is still higher than the
lg gram we got 16
811. now of course that is a mixed
workload so what happens if we do
a gaming test i have gfx bench opened up
right here
i'm going to go ahead and start this
test and we'll see what kind of
difference we get in terms of gaming
performance and it looks like we have a
much bigger difference than we did
the xps scored 43.2 frames per second
compared to
71.9 on the macbook air now that's about
65
more frames per second than the lg
gram whereas previously you only had
about a 25
difference so of course the the macbook
air you don't have a ton of games you
can play on there
but anything that is metal enabled it is
going to perform
very well and now let's push these
machines to their limits i have
cinebench r23
open and uh intel power gadget wouldn't
work but i have another program here so
we can see
the temperatures of this lg the wattage
that's gonna be very interesting and i
also have my thermal camera
so we can see how hot these machines get
specifically
how the lg compares to the macbook air
which is completely
fanless so let's go ahead and get a
baseline reading it looks like the lg
gram the hottest part is at 32 degrees
celsius before we
start and then moving over to macbook
air
we are at 28 very interesting you can
see it's much cooler
even though it does not have a fan so a
lot of that heat
is kind of trapped inside of there let's
go ahead and get started we're going to
do our
10 minute stress test and right away we
got about a spike to about 32
38 39 41 watts so
really high wattage right out of gate
and it looks like we peaked at about 3.7
megahertz so pretty high but it is
starting to come down and we are
almost at 90 degrees celsius now the
macbook air
i do have a terminal command open here
so we're right at 3.2 gigahertz
and a total wattage of 14 and a half
for both our performance course and the
weaker power efficiency cores
it's been a couple minutes and i'm
starting to hear the fan on the lg gram
of course the macbook air is fanless
we're sitting right at 89
90 degrees celsius on the og compared to
84
on the macbook air so it's been eight
minutes so far and we have some very
interesting results first off let's take
a look at thermals
it looks like we're about 47 degrees
celsius on the lg gram
and that's wow yeah that's very very hot
right here
at the top let's go ahead and take a
look at the macbook air
that hottest spot right there you guys
can see it's 40 degrees celsius so quite
a bit cooler
even though it's fanless now as far as
the actual temps
we have a big difference our macbook air
is at 95 degrees
celsius so it is running hot but it's
fanless
where's the lg it is very interesting
the fans
has been barely audible this whole time
ever since it kicked in that first time
but lg is severely limiting the wattage
we're running at 10 watts now
and it was just at about 87.89 but once
it limited that wattage we're down to 69
68 degrees celsius so it's running very
cool
very quiet but very little power and
we're running at 1.6 gigahertz so i'm
very interested to see
what kind of performance difference we
get alright my friends
we have our results and i want you guys
to guess
what the difference is how much faster
is this
fanless macbook air then the lg gram you
guys can just
wait a second and then go down comment
below
it's interesting now this lg actually
just got its best score that has ever
gotten
on this test and yes that is with it
unplugged
it got 34
compared to 7637
so yes that is 2.25 times faster
more than twice as fast and then another
i don't know 25
on top of it is absolutely insane the
difference in performance
it is shocking so let's go ahead and
shut down cinebench
let's get into some real world testing
and here i have premiere pro opened up
on
both machines now premiere isn't very
efficient on uh the macbooks final cut's
way better but we're going to see how
those all those benchmarks and tests
play out in the real world so here i
have a simple 4k
project i have a couple let's apply it
so a little bit of color correction
and let's go ahead and see how it
performs i'm going to start out with
the macbook air let's hit play
glitch there for a second and now we
have perfectly smooth playback looks
like our graphics
is at 95 pretty much maxed out that
seven core gpu
and we are playing back a full 4k
resolution right here not at half res or
anything else
let's go and see how our lg gram
compares
all right it is choppy it is not
smoothing out
and we're getting some weird artifacty
artifacts
as well so it looks like the system
isn't handling the playback
looks like we're dropping i don't know
half half the frames or so
i just enabled the debug mode here so it
looks like we're playing back at 29
frames per second
uh 29.97 so almost perfect on the
macbook air
whereas we are at about 13 so it's
dropping actually about two-thirds 12
and a half
so that's about three times the
performance
for video editing at least the playback
smoothness now of course we can go ahead
and drop
the the lg gram to say half the quality
here
let's try to play back definitely got a
lot smoother but it is still not running
perfectly
oh there you go actually it just hit
right there
30 so definitely a lot better and
visually
you could still use it a half mode on a
screen the size there's not a problem so
now
let's go ahead and stop this and i'm
going to go ahead and export both these
projects
and we'll see how they compare and we
are off i am using adobe
media encoder that way that's going to
tell us how fast it's going
and roughly how long it's going to take
so it's been a few minutes and our
estimated time has calmed down now
it's gotten a lot more stable and we
have a pretty big difference and
i don't think i want to wait this long
for the lg gram
uh based on what the premiere pro's
telling me right now it's gonna take
roughly
30 minutes until this encode is
finished whereas with the macbook air
it's looking like it's going to be
about nine and a half minutes 9 20. i've
actually done this encode already on the
macbook air it took 9 minutes and 30
seconds
compared to right around 28 to 30
minutes on the lg
gram so just like in the timeline where
we saw this was playing back at 12 and a
half 13 frames per second compared to 30
at full quality
i guess exporting we have a similar
result
so basically three times longer three
times worse the performance on the lg
gram
in terms of video editing so that is a
massive difference
and now let's get into photo editing i
have lightroom classic opened up
and i have to mention that this is
optimized for the intel processor it's
not yet optimized for apple's
m1 chip so that does give the lg gram
an advantage and here i have 50 42
megapixel files open
and let's go ahead and see how our real
world performance is so let's go ahead
and punch in
on these massive files and it looks like
cropping in here really tight the
performance is basically identical
no issues and then now how about
switching between these
massive files which all of these
actually have a bunch of editing
effects and color changes stacked on
here
so each time we switch there's a lot of
things going on in the background
and the performance looks to be about
the same
sometimes our m1 switches faster like
that was actually a big difference
sometimes the lg's a little bit quicker
but
pretty good performance now let's grab a
brush and see how that performance is
because it uses a lot of gpu power
and that is actually nice and smooth
on the lg we have maybe have a tiny bit
of delay at first and then it smooths
out
no issues there and on our m1 mac
basically the same so once again we have
maybe a tiny bit of delay at first and
then
nice and smooth and now let's go ahead
and export these images this pushes the
graphics and the cpu
the ram everything i'm going to go ahead
and hit
export here hit my timer and let's see
how long it takes
all right we are close here on the
macbook air
it's right there basically two minutes
and 41 seconds is where it stopped at
and it looks like we're about 75 done on
the lg
we're getting close here it was really
dragging its feet i think once the
wattage turns down like we showed you up
there you go got done
4 minutes and 17 seconds i almost missed
it there
so we have 2 minutes and 41 seconds
compared to 4 minutes and 17 seconds
it's not twice as long but it's kind of
getting there
so that is just shocking difference in
performance
all right guys so what is our final
verdict which one of these machines
should you buy
honestly i may have sounded biased
throughout this video i was trying not
to you guys maybe saw the one against
the macbook pro
at this price point it is just a
slaughter where it is just
embarrassing we have the 999 dollar
macbook air
sometimes even 950 will go ahead and
link it down on amazon below
compared to 1200 bucks and the build
quality is better
the speakers are a lot better the
trackpad is better the webcam is better
the microphone's quieter but the sound
quality is better
the display is way better our graphics
performance is way better the cpu
performance is way better
real world video editing even in
premiere pro is better it's faster in
lightroom
as far as exporting the actual editing
performance is the same
even though it's not yet optimized i
mean it's just
how can you buy the lg gram now of
course lg game has all those ports
it supports better external monitors as
far as battery left that's one thing i
did not cover
it's rated at 25 hours of battery life
but in the real world
dave lee he said he got about nine hours
compared to the macbook air
it's rated at 16 but it gets around 13
or so so real world battery life
is also better i guess if you need to
upgrade your m.2 down
later down the line uh or if you want a
slightly display or if you really want
windows
you should buy it's still a great
windows based system
but the macbook air for the money is
just an absolutely
incredible machine i would just highly
recommend it so
you guys let me know your thoughts down
below click that circle above
if you guys want to subscribe to see
more videos like this one and help us
reach our goal of 600 000 subscribers
that would be amazing we have a couple
great videos right over there
this been max and i'll see you in the
next video